you don't invent technology and then
figure out what to do with it
you come up with an artistic problem and
then you have to invent the technology
in order to accomplish it
i mean when they go after your writing
you're directing
it has to hurt oh it always hurts it
hurts a great deal
but part of making movies is you get
attacked
and sometimes in very personal ways i
start in the middle
it was episode four right from the
beginning because i don't like
beginnings
you know i um like to cut right into the
middle of the action that's kind of what
we do on
indiana jones it's kind of what i do on
american graffiti it's
just you know i like i don't like to do
the exposition part
i write to music so when i'm writing a
scene
i i have the music there and i'm writing
it to the music
and then in a lot of cases we'll use
that same music as a temp track
but if you want to say i want to uh
convey an emotion to another human being
that's something only human beings can
do
that's what you have done you have been
able to create new things
simply because i could have done it
before and you had to do it
on your own because i had a story to
tell yeah
there's a gap between what is possible
and where my vision is and i've had to
fill that gap which is what anybody
you don't invent technology and then
figure out what to do with it
you come up with an artistic problem and
then you have to invent the technology
in order to accomplish it
so it's the opposite of what most people
think it is and any artist will tell you
that
and art on all levels
is just technology which is why
it's you know people say well monkeys
can do paintings well they can't really
they can do they can do scribbling they
can do like
what my two-year-old does but if you
want to say
i want to convey
an emotion to another human being
that's something only human beings can
do animals can do it
by roaring in your face or biting your
hand off and that usually has an effect
but to do it in a painting to do it in a
play or in a store
in a in poetry or anything
that's in the arts you have to be a
human being
tell me about that first script now did
you try to tell the whole story in one
script
well at that point it wasn't the whole
story i was i
wrote a script and the script was um
very ambitious
and told a very large story and
when i finished it i realized that it
was way too big
to make into a movie so i took the first
part of it
sort of the first act i said i'll make
the movie about this
and i had to expand on it and move it
around play with a little bit
but i basically then focused on that as
being the film
and i said someday if i ever get a
chance maybe i'll make these other
things
the rest of the other two thirds into a
movie but right now that's just going to
go on the shelf and i'll leave it there
and so that's really how the first
project came to pass the other part of
it is in order to write
that first script i had to write a
backstory about where darth vader came
from
uh how the kids evolved you know his
wife uh how ben related to all that how
the emperor came to power
and that ended up being the basis for
the projects that i'm working on now
are you happy with the way it all came
out
uh yeah actually i'm very happy you know
i'm very pleased with the whole thing
how worried are you that the critics are
not going to like
this new movie oh i'm not worried at all
they haven't liked any of them really
and they especially haven't liked the
last two so well exactly
you know i mean it can't get any worse
yeah but come on i mean when they go
after your writing you're directing
it has to hurt oh it always hurts it
hurts a great deal
but part of making movies is you get
attacked
and sometimes in very personal ways did
you not say
ever to yourself well maybe they had a
point with this or with that
the point is um it's like uh
if you paint your house white and
somebody comes well that should be a
greenhouse
well fine but i wanted to paint it white
i don't think there's anything wrong
with painting it right i don't think
there's
anything wrong with me for painting it
white maybe it should be a greenhouse
but i didn't want it to be a greenhouse
i want it to be a white house
that's george lucas he knows exactly
what he wants in his movies
hi i'm madeline in project happiness we
are
exploring the difference between short
and long-term happiness
what do you think are the things which
most contribute to long-term happiness
well my theory of short and long-term
happiness
is a broader definition which has to do
with
pleasure and joy happiness is the result
of a combination of pleasure and joy
short-term happiness which you could
call pleasure
and then long-term happiness which you
can call joy
short-term happiness which is pleasure
is uh
self-centered it's all about getting
something it's all about getting
pleasure and so
it's by its very nature short-term
and it's by its very nature it's
additive which means that
if you do something once say you buy a
car the first car you buy is fantastic
it's an amazing experience
you get this thing the second time you
buy a car it's not so amazing
so you have to buy a bigger fancier car
in order to get the same experiences
when you bought your first car
and it just keeps going down until you
have you know six yachts 12 airplanes
and
50 cars and even then
that experience with those will not
equal the first experience you had
so trying to extend pleasure
into a long-term relationship thing
won't work
it just can't pleasure cannot by its
very nature
be long-term it's short-term and
you know it's a little spike that goes
through your life and it makes things
better and
there's nothing wrong with pleasure good
meal
uh you know whatever but um
joy is is different joy once you
have joy it lasts forever uh it doesn't
hit
as high on the scale as pleasure does
pleasurable way up there
but only for a few minutes or maybe for
a few hours or maybe for a few days
but joy goes
on a lower scale but it will last
forever
and joy is as the opposite of
the passion of of and the
self-centeredness of
pleasure is uh compassion giving
helping other people the
uh uh
issue of joy uh really has to do with
taking care of other people and doing
things
for others rather than for yourself
whereas joy it's all for yourself and
not for others
and that's and those two things combined
like happiness
which is also a mental state which you
can either decide you're happier or not
so but the biological reality is
that you have these two components
pleasure and joy you know i made the
decision to
sell the company with star wars i made
that decision
because i looked at the future i looked
at the fact that i was gonna have a baby
i looked at the fact that i was married
and i looked at the fact that i wanted
to build a museum
and i looked at the fact that i wanted
to make experimental films so
my life was going on a different track i
noticed the last few
movies that i made were costing the
company a lot of money
and i didn't think that was fair to the
people that worked there or the company
and so um i had made a decision
to move ahead on the next star wars
series and we were starting to do that
so you were starting to make the next
star wars yeah
you as director filmmaker
so and we were working with a writer it
wasn't quite working out but i was also
you know i was also stepping away a
little bit to
and turning things over to uh kathy
kennedy
and so um what happened was
disney said gee or bob iger said gee if
you really want to sell your company if
you're thinking about selling it because
we were talking about retirement and
what are you going to do after all this
kind of
and he said well you really want to sell
it you know we're very interested
so that started that ball rolling and
i knew from
you know and i had the story treatments
or you know outlines
and um and we were about just we were
working on scripts
and um so i sold it
so i said okay i will
go my way and i'll let them go their way
and it really does come down to
a simple rule of life
which is when you break up with somebody
the first rule is no phone calls the
second rule
you don't go over to their house and
drive by to see what they're doing
the third one is you don't show up at
their coffee shop or the things that
you're gonna bring
you just say no gone history i'm moving
forward
because every time you do and you know
we all learn this from experience
every time you do something like that
you're opening the wound again
and it just makes it harder for you you
have to put it behind you and it's a
very very very hard thing to
do but you have to just cut it off and
say okay end the ball game
i got to move on and everything in your
body says don't
you can't these are my kids
so all those star wars all the star wars
films they were your kids
yeah well they are right you know i i
love them i created them
um i'm very intimately involved in them
and
obviously to solve them i sold them to
the
white slavers that take these things and
and okay but i mean but but having said
all that and having talked to you for
the last
and and known you for a while and
admired you
i mean it must hurt you well
it's
and i knew that was going to probably
take you know to do it right would take
about 10 years
and i said i'm 70. i don't know whether
i'll be here when i'm 80.
you know every 10 years at the odds get
less and
uh so i said and i'm not ready to do
that because i want to do these other
things
so i have to make the decision on my own
that it's time for me to move on why did
you start in the middle of the star wars
story and then go back to the beginning
well originally star wars was one simple
little movie
based on a saturday matinee cereal the
idea was that you came in you saw
episode four
you know what happened before you know
what happened after
the original script this it was one
script it started with darth vader
coming in the front door
it ended with darth vader throwing the
emperor down the tube
i start in the middle it was episode
four right from the beginning because
i don't like beginnings you know i um
like to cut right into the middle of the
action that's kind of what we do on
indiana jones it's
kind of what i do on american graffiti
it's just you know i like i don't like
to do the exposition part
um but if you start in episode four you
still have to write
the back story the exposition in order
to know where you're going you do a
little
profile on each of the characters who
they are where they came from what their
feelings are about things
and in this case the sort of political
atmosphere of the
republic and the empire how did the
republic become the empire
and everybody's role in that and that's
really what was the back story
when i finished star wars i figured that
was it
once i finished return of the jedi and i
never really expected to go back and
turn the the backstory into a movie
i had known stephen spielberg for a long
time
up to this point and uh you know i was
we were talking about the film real
early on when i was writing the script
and i said you know i want you know i
want a classical score
you know i want the you know the the uh
corn gold kind of feel about this thing
it's a it's an
old-fashioned kind of movie and and i
want that grand
soundtrack that you used to have on
movies
and he said the guy you got to talk to
is john williams you know he did jaws
i love him he's the greatest composer
ever lived
you gotta talk to him that's what i did
it was really steven that introduced us
and
and recommended him
you know i talked to him and said okay
he was interested
so he he did it and he's a dream to work
with you know it's
the he's the most wonderful collaborator
didn't you at first want him to use
existing classical music is that true
no no i had i had written it to certain
pieces of music i
write to music so when i'm writing a
scene i
i have the music there and i'm writing
it to the music
and then in a lot of cases we'll use
that same music as a temp track
so there was temp tracks of classical
music in the score
and and with johnny you can say look i
want something it feels exactly like
this
you know just you understand the emotion
here and the emotion there and
what's going on he said yeah yeah yeah
and then he will take that and he will
come up with his own composition
and his own themes which are uniquely
you know star wars themes in this case
and but he'll give it that same
emotional
thrust that was in the in the classical
piece he knows exactly what i'm talking
about and he's
really conscious of trying to get the
director's vision
uh on the screen uh what's the best
metaphor of the story
you think it is in terms of you know you
can interpret it in all sorts of
political
social ways what's the best metaphor for
you
well it's ultimately uh a
discussion about how fragile democracy
is
and how uh democracies
sometimes get turned over to tyrants
with applause and that
we should always be vigilant as citizens
to make sure that doesn't happen
the other one is to look inside
ourselves and see what kind of a person
are we
are we a good person or an evil person
we're all
we all have both of those components
in us and we choose to be
out of balance so to speak and we can
choose to be more evil than good
and if that happens we should look at
ourselves and say i think i'm doing the
right thing
but am i harming others am i doing this
for selfish reasons
am i you know only concerned about
myself or
my compassion and caring about other
people
life is fluid you're always given
opportunities
and choices
generally speaking no choice i mean no
decision
is the worst decision because you always
have these decisions to make
and you know if you go with your heart
and do what you think is right
uh generally it'll take you in the right
place because to say then you'll be
doing things you love
and even if you're doing something that
is
you know you decide to be a gardener
and that's really what you want to do
and that's what gives you pleasure then
be a gardener
even though your father and your friends
may say why aren't you a lawyer
because you can be a lawyer you got
accepted to law school why you want to
be a gardener say well i like this
you know you'll find that you'll be much
happier
because you know money can't buy you
happiness
and that's been proven a million times
it can buy you pleasure
but it's not going to everybody's
happiness and over time
not you can't make enough money to buy
you pleasure anymore because
you need so much to keep you going
so it's better to get in there with joy
because it doesn't cost you anything
thank you what kind of feedback did you
get to that incredible
climactic scene in empire when we all
learn
who darth vader really is i was nervous
about it but in the end i didn't get
much a reaction out of it
i mean people you know were curious
about whether it was true or not
and i purposely left it so that would be
ambiguous so that
you wouldn't really know and people
would sort of debate it for the next
week
two more years or more to
you know i wanted people to sort of
debate whether it's true or not true or
like
sort of thing
you